>> MY FIRST GUEST TONIGHT IS
THE UKRAINE FOREIGN MINISTER
DMYTRO KULEBA.
HE'S CUT SHORT A TOUR OF
AFRICAN WORK HE APPEALS FOR THE
CONTINENTS SUPPORT NOW MORE
THAN EVER.
HE'S JOINING ME NOW.
WELCOME TO THE PROGRAM, A
FOREIGN MINISTER.
>> IT'S MY PLEASURE --
LET ME ASK YOU WHAT'S --
YOU'RE TAKING TIME OUT OF A
BUSY DAY.
WHAT CAN YOU SAY TO CONFIRM
WHAT HAPPENS.
AND WHAT IS YOUR MESSAGE THIS
TIME?
>> THOUGH I'M AWAY BUT
EVERYTHING LITERALLY HAPPENS IN
FRONT OF MY FAMILY IN KYIV.
SOME PEOPLE WHO I KNOW IN KYIV.
MY KIDS WERE LITERALLY 800
METERS AWAY FROM THE BRIDGE.
THE RUSSIAN MICHEL HIT THE
DOWNTOWN KYIV.
I KNOW A WOMAN WHO WAS KILLED
BY RUSSIAN MISSILE AT A
CROSSROAD, LEAVING HER CHILD IN
ORPHAN.
BECAUSE HER HUSBAND HAD BEEN
KILLED SIX MONTHS AGO.
THESE ARE THE STORIES.
DEATHS OF CIVILIANS, THREAT TO
CIVILIANS AND MASSIVE, MASSIVE
DESTRUCTION OF ENERGY
INFRASTRUCTURE ACROSS THE
COUNTRY TO MAKE THE LIFE OF
CIVILIANS AS DIFFICULT AS IT
CAN BE.
>> YOU KEEP SAYING CIVILIANS.
WHICH I ASSUME IS DELIBERATE.
OBVIOUSLY, THEY ARE TARGETS AND
THEY ARE KILLED AND WOUNDED.
BUT WAS THERE ANY MILITARY
INFRASTRUCTURE OR ANY OTHER
INFRASTRUCTURE.
YOU MENTIONED ENERGY.
ANYTHING ELSE THAT THEY
TARGETED?
AS OF >> NOW I'M AWARE THAT THE
VAST MAJORITY OF TARGETS WERE
ENERGY FACILITIES.
WE STILL HAVE SOME PARTS OF
UKRAINE BLACKED OUT.
AND I'M NOT AWARE OF ANY MAJOR
MILITARY FACILITY THAT WAS
TARGETED.
IT WAS ONLY ENERGY FACILITIES
AND CIVILIAN HOUSES, APARTMENT
BUILDING.
THIS IS JUST A CROSSROAD INTO
DOWNTOWN KYIV.
THERE SHOULD BE NO DOUBT THAT
THE GOAL OF THIS ATTACK WAS TO
TERRORIZE PEACEFUL POPULATION
AND TO MAKE THEIR LIFE AS
DIFFICULT AS POSSIBLE.
I'M PRETTY, SURE I'M CONFIDENT
THAT THIS IS THE RESULT OF
PUTIN'S DEFEAT ON THE
BATTLEGROUND.
WHEN HIS ARMY CANNOT BE
UKRAINIAN ARMY.
HE CHOOSES TO TERRORIZE
CIVILIANS IN RESPONSE AS
REVENGE.
>> FOREIGN MINISTER, IT LOOKS
LIKE HE LASHED OUT SPECIFICALLY
BECAUSE OF WHAT HAPPENED ON THE
BRIDGE OVER THE WEEKEND.
DID UKRAINE DO THAT?
THEY BLAME YOU FOR THE ACT OF
TERRORISM AND THEY ACCUSE YOUR
SECURITY SERVICES INTELLIGENCE
SERVICES OF BEING BEHIND THIS
PLOT.
DID UKRAINE DO THIS?
>> LET'S START BY SAYING THAT
RUSSIA BLAMES UKRAINE FOR BEING
UKRAINE.
RUSSIA FINDS THIS GUILTY
BECAUSE WE EXIST.
THIS IS THE STARTING POINT.
I THINK THAT THE NARRATIVE TO
SAY THAT UKRAINE NEEDS TO BE
BLAMED FOR SOMETHING IS WRONG
AND MISLEADING.
I'M NOT BLAMING YOU PERSONALLY
ABOUT THIS IS SOMETHING I'M
HEARING SINCE 24TH OF FEBRUARY.
AS REGARDS TO THE BRIDGE.
I'M TRAVELING I HAVE NO ACCESS
TO CONFIDENTIAL INFORMATION
FROM HERE.
SO I REALLY DON'T KNOW WHO BLEW
UP THE BRIDGE.
I WOULDN'T EXCLUDE --
SOMETHING HAPPENING INSIDE OF
RUSSIA BECAUSE THIS BRIDGE IS
SO HEAVILY PROTECTED FROM ALL
SIDES.
AGAIN, AS LONG AS THEY DON'T
HAVE INFORMATION TO OUR
INTELLIGENCE, IT WILL BE
IMPOSSIBLE FOR ME TO CLEARLY
SAY WHAT HAPPENS.
OTHERS HAVE SUGGESTED THAT
PRESIDENT PUTIN IS LASHING OUT
EMOTIONALLY.
THERE ARE LOTS OF ARTICLES THAT
ARE BEGINNING TO SAY THAT
TODAY.
AND THAT PEOPLE ARE CONCERNED,
THERE ARE MOUNTING CONCERNS
ABOUT WHAT HE MIGHT KEEP DOING
AND WHY KEEP ESCALATING.
DO YOU AGREE THAT THERE IS AN
ESCALATORY LADDER UNDERWAY
RIGHT NOW AND WILL WHAT
HAPPENED AROUND YOUR COUNTRY
TODAY CAUSE YOU TO RETHINK YOUR
OFFENSIVES AND YOUR COUNTER
OFFENSIVES TO LIBERATE YOUR
TERRITORIES OUT OF UNOCCUPIED
AND SEIZED?
>> NO WAY.
NOTHING.
WHATEVER HE DOES, WHATEVER HE
DOES, WE WILL CONTINUE TO
LIBERATE OUR TERRITORY.
I WANT TO UNDERSTAND A VERY
SIMPLE THING.
THIS IS THE WAR FOR THE
EXISTENCE OF UKRAINE.
EXISTENCE OF INTERNATIONAL LAW
AND RULE-BASED ORDER.
SO HE MAY ESCALATE, HE MAY DO
WHATEVER HE WANTS.
WE WERE GOING TO CONTINUE
FIGHTING.
THAT'S EXACTLY WE'RE TRYING TO
DO.
--
WHAT DO YOU NEED SPECIFICALLY.
WE HEAR SOME OF YOUR UKRAINIAN
GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS MILITARY
OFFICIALS --
TALKING ABOUT A NEED FOR MUCH
MORE REGULAR SUPPLY OF
ARTILLERY AND AMMUNITION.
FOR AIR DEFENSES, WE UNDERSTAND
YOUR PRESIDENT SPOKE TO THE
PRESIDENT OF FRANCE.
AND RAISED THE ISSUE OF AIR
DEFENSES.
ET CETERA, TANKS, ARMORED
PERSONNEL CARRIERS, NOT TO
MENTION WINTER UNIFORMS IN
ORDER TO BE ABLE TO FIGHT THE
VERY COLD MONTHS AHEAD.
WHAT DO YOU NEED RIGHT NOW
ESPECIALLY AS YOU SEE WHAT'S
JUST HAPPENED?
>> I DON'T KNOW HOW MANY MORE
CIVILIANS HAVE TO DIE.
HOW MANY MORE CITIES HAVE TO BE
DESTROYED FOR ALL THE COUNTRIES
WHO POSSESS AIR DEFENSE AN ANTI
MISSILE DEFENSE WEAPONS TO
SHARE THEM WITH US.
AND WE ARE READY TO ENGAGE IN
DIFFERENT MODELS OF SHARING.
WE NEED TO PROTECT OUR
CIVILIANS.
IF WE ARE CONFIDENT THAT WE ARE
ABLE TO PROTECT THEM WE WILL BE
EVEN MORE SUCCESSFUL ON THE
BATTLEGROUND.
THE ONLY FIELD --
THEATER IN THIS WAR WHERE
RUSSIA HAS MORE ADVANTAGES THAN
WE DO IS MISSILE DEFENSE.
THIS IS REALLY THE PROBLEM THAT
WE HAVE TO ADDRESS IMMEDIATELY.
AND IN EVERY CONVERSATION THAT
I HAD TODAY, EVERY SINGLE
CONVERSATION WHEN INTERNATIONAL
PARTNERS.
I MADE THAT POINT CLEAR.
THEY ARE AN ANTI MISSILE
DEFENSE NUMBER ONE.
IT'S TRUE WE ARE FIGHTING A WAR
YOU NEED EVERYTHING.
LITERALLY, FOR ME TO Z.
BUT WE WANT TO PROTECT
CIVILIANS.
WE WANT TO PROTECT CITIES.
IF WE DO THAT, WE WILL KNOW
THAT EVERYTHING IS SAFE IN OUR
--
WE WILL MOVE FORWARD.
>> YOU'VE BEEN IN AFRICA.
YOU'RE TRYING TO GET SUPPORT
FROM THE CONTINENT.
YOUR CUTTING SHORT YOUR TRIP TO
GO BACK TO DEAL WITH THIS
CRISIS.
AFRICA AND MANY OTHER PARTS OF
THE WORLD THE GLOBAL SOUTH AS
YOU KNOW BETTER THAN I DO HAVE
NOT JOINED THE SANCTIONS
AGAINST RUSSIA.
THEY'VE BEEN SUSCEPTIBLE TO
VLADIMIR PUTIN'S NARRATIVE.
PARTICULARLY ON THE FOOD
POVERTY.
EVEN THE HEAD OF THE AFRICAN
UNION.
REPEATED WHAT PRESIDENT PUTIN
SAID ABOUT --
IT'S THE WAR, IT'S UKRAINE.
IT IS HOLDING UP GRAIN EVEN
THOUGH THERE ARE NO SANCTIONS
AGAINST THAT.
HAVE YOU HAD ESPECIALLY IN
LIGHT OF WHAT JUST HAPPENED
ANYTHING THAT MAKES YOU FEEL
THAT AFRICA OR OTHER COUNTRIES
THAT ARE RELUCTANT MIGHT BACK
YOU MORE NOW >> YES BUT WE NEED
TO TALK MORE WITH THEM.
I CAN TELL YOU ONE STORY JUST
TO GIVE YOU A GLIMPSE OF THIS
ENGAGEMENT HERE.
THE NARRATIVE THAT RUSSIA HELPS
AFRICA A LOT IS QUITE
WIDESPREAD HERE ACROSS THE
CONTINENT.
AND WHEN YOU MAKE IT A POINT
THAT RUSSIA IS NOT EVEN CLOSE
ON THE LIST OF INVESTORS OR
PROVIDERS OF HUMANITARIAN AID
TO AFRICA.
AND THE BIGGEST INVESTMENT IS
MADE IN AFRICA IS THE --
THAT CHANGES THE OPTICS.
AND THAT MAKES PEOPLE THINK.
BUT WE HAVE TO TALK WITH THEM.
WE HAVE TO CONVINCE THEM AND WE
HAVE TO TELL THE TRUTH.
ABOUT, IT'S SO IT WILL TAKE
TIME.
I'M SURE THAT THEY WILL BE
CHANGING POSITIONS.
>> DO YOU EXPECT TO NATO AND
OTHER ALLIES WHO ARE FIRMLY GOT
YOUR BACK.
THERE IS GOING TO BE APPARENTLY
AN EMERGENCY G7 CALL TOMORROW
BETWEEN LEADERS INCLUDING YOUR
PRESIDENT.
THERE IS GOING TO BE A PLANNED
NATO DEFENSE MINISTER IS
MEETING.
TOWARDS THE END OF THIS WEEK.
GIVEN WHAT HAPPENED TODAY.
GIVEN --
WHAT ARE YOU EXPECTING?
>> SO MY PRESIDENT HAS HELD A
NUMBER OF INTERNATIONAL CALLS
TODAY.
I AM SPEAKING WITH FOREIGN
MINISTERS IN --
G7 SUMMIT WILL BE TOMORROW WITH
THE PARTICIPATION OF PRESENTS A
LANDSCAPE.
THERE WILL BE A LOT OF
INTERNATIONAL ENGAGEMENTS.
WHAT WE'RE ASKING FOR IS
DECISIONS.
WE APPRECIATE EVERY WORD OF
CONDEMNATION AND EVERYWHERE TO
SUPPORT.
THIS IS REALLY HELPFUL.
YOU CANNOT WIN THE WAR ONLY
WITH WORDS.
YOU NEED WEAPONS, YOU NEED
HARDWARE.
AND YOU NEED FURTHER ISOLATION
OF RUSSIA THROUGH SANCTIONS.
THROUGH A VERY SIMPLE DECISION
NOT TO SHAKE HANDS OF PRESIDENT
PUTIN.
ALL OF THESE THINGS.
THEY MUST HAPPEN.
SOONER OR LATER, THEY MUST BE
HAPPENING AND THESE ATTACKS
THAT OCCURRED TODAY.
THEY ACTUALLY MAKE A VERY
STRONG POINT THAT ALL OF THIS
HAS TO HAPPEN SOONER RATHER
THAN LATER.